ich wünsche euch einen wunderschönen
guten Morgen meine lieben Freunde es ist
8:30 Uhr und ich habe jetzt Boxtraining
wenn ihr mir auf Instagram folgt wisst
ihr dass ich schon seit einem Jahr boxe
aber immer mal so ein paar Wochen am
Stück dann wieder ein paar Monate Pause
und jetzt will ich wirklich komplett
durchziehen wieder anfangen und dachte
mir ich nehme euch einfach mal mit vor
allem weil mein Trainer halt auch ein
total korrekter du bist ein Pimmel
ziehen coole Box Sachen
junge locker locker beweg dich schön
locker beweg dich ich beweg mich doch
nicht die Arme die Beine auf dem Kopf
zurückziehen beschützt nicht deine
Titten sehen
ich gehe beweg dich beweg dich beweg
dich mehr beweg mich doch nennen um den
sensack nicht
gefilmt hat dass ich schon 20 Minuten da
gesprintelt
worden
Alter der ist kurz unter die Dusche
gegangen genauso
sehr deine Mutter beleidigt los
[Musik]
ja man zurück
genau
und runter
gemacht seine Oberarme liegen auch halt
nichts Alter ne das war gar kein Gewicht
im Gehirn ist halt auch kein nichts drin
so Bro sagst du 10:30 Uhr heißt 11:30
Uhr in der Kamera sagen ich bin neu in
der Branche ob der noch nie was anderes
in den Mund genommen hat
[Musik]
4 3 3 und runter 30 Liter langsam
reichen ich die 400 Essen
weiterzuziehen komm hoch
und Pause
15 Sekunden Pause und dann 15 Sekunden
wieder
das ist meine Augenhöhe weil ihm
eigentlich
du vergisst dass ich in Marathon
gelaufen ist
Training ist durch ich fahre jetzt noch
5 Minuten Fahrrad zum aus
machen
ich schwöre
das einzige was noch schlimmer ist als
Boxen ist wenn du in deinem Auto was du
seit drei Monaten hast plötzlich so ein
Steinschlag hast und was mir auch immer
erst auffällt wenn die Sonne scheint ist
dass man einfach bei diesem Lack jedes
einzelne Drecksding mit Erde sieht alle
meine Kollegen meinten und den GT3 holst
muss eine richtig krasse exotische Farbe
nehmen ich dachte mir halt so ey sondern
gelb und PTS war richtig wild aber man
sieht halt wirklich jeden Dreck
ich habe dich trotzdem lieb
ich bin so Single Alter
ja
war wisst was ich übertrieben hast du
eigentlich wenn vlogger nicht so gucken
sondern so
oder so
nicht so in die Kamera sondern einfach
in den Bildschirm darüber sich selbst
die ganze Zeit angucken aber jetzt mache
ich das selber schon ich muss immer
wieder reinkommen ich habe jetzt
tatsächlich seit sage und schreibe
sieben Stunden
nichts geblockt ich Film auch immer von
der anderen Mann so hi leute was geht
ich zeige euch heute mal ein bisschen
was das jetzt mein Bett und man sieht
auf jeden Fall dass ich Single bin nee
quatsch Freunde die Taschentücher stehen
dir natürlich welche erkältet bin
ja
das kann ich euch noch zeigen
ah guck mal hier ganz spannend das ist
meine Waschmaschine
oh die ist fertig dann wird jetzt mal
schön Wäsche aufgehangen meine lieben
Freunde
hi
äh ich habe nicht genug Geld für das
Fischeier Objektiv deswegen seht ihr
mich jetzt gerade nicht aber stellt euch
einfach vor wie ich gerade zwei Hosen
aus der Waschmaschine rausholen und
diese jetzt aufhängen muss
dafür greifen wir uns natürlich hier den
Wäscheständer
hätte ich auch mal wieder gern und
packen den Wäscheständer tatsächlich
wieder zurück denn ich habe eine bessere
Idee und zwar gehen wir in mein
Badezimmer rein schmeißen einfach dieses
Handtuch hier runter das muss eh kein
Mensch weil ich alleine wohne jetzt
können wir hier drüber einfach die Hose
ja was ist mit der zweiten machweise
nicht glaube ich hänge die zweite
einfach hier vorne über den
Handtuchhalter weil auch hier keine zwei
hi
mein Stativ ist kaputt deswegen kann die
Kamera
vielleicht soll ich mal ein bisschen
Geld in meinem Beruf investieren ich
friere einfach am ganzen Körper weil
diese Heizung auch nicht läuft ne das
ist nicht nur ein Fußboden sondern eine
Fußbodenheizung aber die Fußbodenheizung
heizt nicht weil die
fußbodenheizungsverteiler sein Wärme
Wasser nicht ganz richtig
ja da kam was mit ich liebe vloggen ne
das ist
nojo für mich ist das wie so eine Art
Therapie ich kann mir einfach alles von
der Leber quatschen was ein irgendwie so
aufregt aber perfekt nächste Sache ich
habe so eine Milchglas Spraydose gekauft
und wollte das Fenster zu Milchglas
machen hat super geklappt Kamera hallo
genau genommen schlage ich gerade nur
die Zeit tot bis mein Kollege filo
rumkommt weil mit dem gehe ich zusammen
ins Stadion Vierrad wird auch noch mit
ein paar Kollegen da sind die werden wir
auch noch sehen und Köln spielt gegen
irgendwie Kreise mich in letzter Zeit zu
viele Helikopter über die Stadt
[Musik]
die Waschmaschine ist fertig die habe
ich eigentlich vor 2 Sekunden
weggeschmissen Köln spielt auf jeden
Fall nicht gegen Roter Stern Belgrad was
glaube ich im Belgrad die bessere
Fußballmannschaft ist sondern gegen
Partizan Belgrad
das wird eine Party wegen Party dann ist
ja ein bisschen
da vorne sind die guten und wenn wir
nicht mögen
sind die da können liegt übrigens hinten
[Musik]
Stadion immer wenn jemand im Stadion ist
verliert der FC Köln das stimmt nicht
die Belgrad Spieler liegen die ganze
Zeit am Boden ihr seht komplett aus alle
zwei Sekunden muss irgendwie Sanitäter
kommen und die 800 auswärts übertrieben
in Köln kauft das Eis ich kann euch nur
eiskriminalität empfehlen ich bin gerade
wieder zu Hause angekommen denk mir
nichts böses geh eine Wohnung drücke
hoffentlich Schalter was haben wir
Stromausfall
ob ich Angst habe quatsch ich denke mal
solche Momenten allerdings immer positiv
denken Kopf nicht hängen lassen
wenigstens hat der FC gewonnen
scheiße